Ruth y sunac en la misma línea los dos
dirigentes quieren federar el mayor
número de Estados en torno a su proyecto
y mandar f-16 a kiev pero ni Londres ni
Berlín disponen de Tales aviones
lo que obviamente podemos aportar ese
entrenamiento y apoyo de nuevos dentro
de unos límites Porque no tenemos
pilotos de f-16 depende de la Casa
Blanca decidir si quieren liberar esa
tecnología
por lo que yo se corresponde la Casa
Blanca decidir si se pueden entregar
casas f-16 y si se puede organizar el
entrenamiento con esos aviones no es una
cuestión que se resuelva en Berlín
porque el constructor de estos cazadores
es estadounidense maniobrable y rápido
el f-16 está bien ligero lleva misiles
bombas y cohetes equipadas las fuerzas
de unos 25 países en Varsovia se invoca
la falta de medios según el presidente
duda su país no está en condiciones de
proporcionar a kiev aviones de combate
f-16 Pero puede formar a pilotos en el
uso de estos aparatos lo mismo puede
decirse de Bruselas nuestros f-16 han
llegado poco a poco al final de su ciclo
de vida es imposible donarlos también
los necesitamos Para nuestras misiones
nacionales y en el marco de nuestras
obligaciones internacionales si Francia
acepta formar a soldados ucranianos en
el manejo de los Migajas 2000 el
presidente macun se niega por el momento
a confirmar el despliegue de este tipo
de aviones de combate en Ucrania